a stunning revelation the FBI is
admitting it mishandled a very specific
tip about Nicholas Cruz the 19 year old
accused of murdering 17 people at a high
school earlier this week
someone warned the bureau last month of
almost exactly what happened Wednesday
afternoon the warning was ignored the
second tip from a member of the public
about Cruz that failed to prevent the
massacre that revelation comes as the
funerals begin for some of the victims
correspondent Phil Keating is at the
shooting scene in parkland Florida
good evening Phil good evening Mike
warning flags were flying high and
flying for a very long time specifically
about the 19 year old former student of
Stoneman Douglas High School behind me
now accused of 17 counts of first degree
murder just about an hour ago Broward
County Sheriff
said over the past few years his office
received 20 calls for service
specifically about Cruz and his behavior
at the time he says such calls for
service in the future will now be far
more swar while scrutinized
also at the FBI and Justice Department
today a stunning public admission two
days after the worst high school
shooting in US history a massacre the
FBI was warned could happen the agency
now admits it failed to properly handle
a January 5th tip from a person close to
Nicholas Cruz about the suspects gun
ownership and his alleged desire to kill
people specifically to carry out a
school shooting that should have been
forwarded up as a potential threat to
life to the Miami field office it was
not five weeks later 17 students and
teachers are dead on behalf of myself
and over 1,000 employees of the Miami
field office we truly regret any
additional pain that this is caused in
an equally rare slap from the Attorney
General to his FBI Jeff Sessions
released a highly critical admonition
quote it is now clear that the warning
signs were there and tips to the FBI
were missed we see the tragic
consequences of those failures and
Florida Governor Rick Scott taking the
outrage even further quote the FBI's
failure to take action against this
killer is unacceptable 17 innocent
people are dead and acknowledging a
mistake isn't going to cut it the FBI
director needs to resign also in
September the FBI was unable to trace
the source of an Internet post by
someone with the same name as the
suspect writing I'm going to be a
professional school shooter and Broward
County Sheriff now clarifying what the
alleged killer brought with him the
killer never was in possession of a gas
mask or any type of smoke grenades the
former student expelled last year for
disciplinary reasons 19 year old
Nicholas Cruz remains held without bond
he's remorseful he is fully aware of
what is going on
and he's just a broken human being
emotions and politics continue to
dominate this affluent community while
across the country schools and police
are dealing with copycat threats most
have been social media hoaxes and the
devastation caused by the shooting for
the community led several thousand
people to gather together Thursday night
at the parkland amphitheater for an
emotional candlelight vigil this student
lost a close friend I think that he
would appreciate what we're doing and I
think that people would want him to
remember in a positive way and just out
tonight by the Florida Sun Sentinel
quoting Nicholas Cruz's public defender
Cruz is now agreeing to plead guilty to
first-degree murder 17 counts of that
for killing 14 students a teacher a high
school football coach and an athletic
director all in exchange for avoiding
the death penalty and also the freshman
building the free story structure on
campus where all of the killing haven't
will now be demolished so that none of
the surviving students and teachers will
ever have to walk past those classrooms
of carnage again Mike our Phil Keating
live in parkland Florida after a
heartbreaking week there Phil thanks
very much